here is a Woman by well I assume she's a
woman she looks like a woman to me but
she might have a penis who knows anymore
her name is Jesse pocock
a Woman by the name of Jesse pocock she
is the CEO and executive director of
inside out Youth Services advocacy
organization
and she was being questioned on C-Span
about whether parents have rights
related to their children going through
these processes and whether parents
should know that their kids are on
hormones Etc once again we are doing a
trans segment here and the expert her
name is Jesse pocock
pocock person is safe and protected we
have uh we are constantly filing reports
of abuse and neglect because of parents
I understand the cases of people it
sounds like you're deflecting the
question a little bit uh I understand
cases that abuse there's laws to protect
abuse I mean schools actually are
legally obligated to report cases of
abuse same for churches and and the like
anyone who deals with young people but
you know do parents have a right should
they be informed about what's going on
do they have a right to know what's
going on in their kids lives
so I think again
those of us who are protecting and
supporting young people are there and
trusted with the information of the
things that they are dealing with in
terms of parents rights to know at
schools I mean here in Colorado parents
don't have the right if a young person
is questioning their gender or their
sexuality there are laws in place that
say that they have the right to process
that with their trusted counselor and so
forth you do a significant amount of
your work with kids even starting at age
13. yeah
what what would be the age of consent
then in your in your mind
uh in our community the age of consent
to mental health therapy is 12 years old
so the woman who wants to talk to your
children about transitioning and
sexuality and everything else just one
more time her name is Mrs pocock
could have been Moco or less [ __ ] that
would have made more sense
she believes that as she said that we
have people who are protecting and
supporting kids
um I could have sworn that was the job
of the parent I don't want pocock
talking to my children pocock will not
come near my children and pocock
shouldn't come near your children do you
think that there's any chance as as the
representative laid out there so she
thinks a 13 year old can walk into her
office and ask about
puberty blockers surgery Etc et cetera
do you think there is any chance that
when that happens so let's let's say
it's a guy did a boy last time so let's
say it's a girl right so a little girl
comes in and she says you know I feel
like a boy I feel I'm 13 years old I
feel like a boy I like baseball I don't
really like dresses whatever do you
think there's any chance in high hell
that pocock and her minions say you know
what actually you're just going through
a phase and by the way there are some
girls that like baseball and sometimes
they turn out to be lesbians sometimes
not they're you know there's a whole
spectrum of things these are the people
who love like the whole spectrum and
diversity and the quality of everything
and all that stuff but for some reason
with gender and sex if you feel a little
bit different if you're not freaking you
know nail polish blonde and doing your
thing then you are automatically a dude
it's absolutely crazy and these people
should have nothing to do with anyone
else's children